after a year of major announcements
quite a few games are on the way and
players around the world
are waiting anxiously to get their hands
on them let's take a look at some of the
most anticipated games that are
confirmed to arrive in 2021
and if you want to stay up to date on
any of the games we're talking about
today
then make sure you like and subscribe to
our channel
what the hell
the mass effect legendary edition is a
remaster of the mass effect trilogy
announced for spring 2021 while remakes
come
in many forms these days bioware stated
in a blog post that its goal was not to
remake or reimagine the original games
but to modernize the experience so that
fans and new players
can experience the original work in its
best possible form
this will also be an opportunity for
longtime fans to relive the trilogy and
for new players to discover the history
of mass effect
before the release of its next big
chapter a currently
unnamed game that was announced at the
game awards
[Music]
traverse across worlds in multiple
realities with our old friends ratchet
and clank
ratchet and clank rift apart is a third
person shooter that utilizes the power
of the ps5
to avoid loading screens entirely and
makes use of the ps5's dual sense
controller's features
haptic feedback and all it's up to you
to stop dr nefarious yet again
from destroying life on not only your
universe but every existing universe
you'll even be revisiting planets from
past games too
that may not be an easy task but ratchet
clank and a currently unnamed female
wombacks are the ones for the job
ratchet
who
play as batgirl nightwing red hood or
robin in gotham knights
an open world action rpg that is set in
its own universe
and takes place after the death of
batman a new criminal underworld has
taken over gotham city
and you can save the city solo or in
two-player co-op
we've already had a peek into the chaos
from dc fandom
including combat against familiar
villains like mr freeze
how difficulty is determined by your
character's level and in-game
progression
the storm has risen over
nothing can stop it we'll see about that
[Music]
if you're feeling bummed you never got
your letter from hogwarts
then hogwarts legacy might be the best
way to soothe the pain
this rpg is set in the late 1800s where
you play as a hogwarts student
you can do a variety of things such as
attending classes at the iconic school
casting spells and visiting locations
like the forbidden forest and hogsmeade
aside from all the magical possibilities
you can't forget about the morality
system
your path in the wizarding world will be
determined by the choices
you make the legacy of
[Music]
left 4 dead is getting a spiritual
successor and it's almost here
back for blood is not only developed by
the same team behind left 4 dead
but it's already shaping up to be
exactly what fans have been looking for
the co-op zombie survival game brings
back a familiar formula with a polished
look
back for blood adds an emphasis to
tactical team play while not losing the
charm of zombie horror games
providing a variety of unique special
zombies and plenty of different weapons
to kill them with
this game is designed with replayability
in mind as well
allowing you to enhance your character
and your teammates through different
cards that give you buffs and perks
changing your experience with every
level
take a minute people
life and in death we give
glory the bell tolls for us all
they're coming again
[Laughter]
resident evil village is bringing a
unique experience in the survival horror
genre
set in a world that its developers have
described as beautiful
but terrifying the story takes place
several years after the events of
resident evil 7.
we've already seen a few 4k trailers
that show off the unsettling beauty of
the game
but we still haven't had a chance to see
how the quick loading times and new
mechanics
will make village as capcom says the
most immersive
resident evil to date
[Applause]
[Music]
father
sony's santa monica studio is returning
with a follow-up to
2018's god of war the first and so far
only teaser trailer for the unnamed god
of war sequel
reveals nothing more than the game's
logo but the confirmation of getting a
sequel in 2021
has been enough to get fans excited and
get them
analyzing given how god of war ends many
fans assume this sequel will involve
ragnarok in some capacity
reddit users have also tried to decipher
a code finding that it may point towards
freya having a big role in the sequel
but that hasn't been confirmed yet
all of our unanswered questions and
unentered realms will have to be
revisited next year
you must prepare yourself
[Music]
[Music]
halo infinite was originally set for
2020 but was delayed to 2021 to ensure
the quality of the game
meets the franchise's standards when the
game is finally in our hands expect a
single player campaign
with a renewed focus on master chief in
its story and of course
a multiplayer mode we've seen a few
tweaks to gameplay so far
including a grappling hook and a
reintroduction of sprinting and sliding
i'm already eager to play but i'm also
willing to wait however long it's
necessary to do chief justice
2021 is already looking stacked so which
games are you looking forward to the
most
we also have a few videos on our channel
for 2021 games
specifically for either the ps5 or the
xbox series x
so feel free to check those out if you
want to see what else is on the way
thanks for watching like subscribe and
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you